Freak bitches if you care about what you
do,
that's just part of the program.
Absolutely.
And that's it.
There's a healthy part to that.
And then like moving on from it is,
it's easier now than it used to be.
It would just,
it would live in me for a while,
like,
oh dude,
you forgot the words of that song.
And then it becomes a mental block to
get up there and you go,
oh shit.
Like,
uh,
you know,
like a kicker or something,
a guy going to kick a field goal.
It's like,
Oh,
I missed that one.
I can't believe I did.
Then the next one,
oh my God,
now it's a thing,
you know?
Oh,
so getting over those mental blocks.
Fighters lose a fight and then they come
back and then you see the discomfort.
You can see the confusion and the fear
and that's,
uh,
that's one of the side,
I think,
psychological issues or some of the
hardest issues that people ever
overcome.
And it's just literally like a pattern
of thought in your mind or if you just
decide that you're not as good as you
used to be,
you can manifest that and they're like,
physically you can do all the same
things.
That is so crazy.
The power of thought.
The power of my mind is it's pretty
dangerous at times and being creative
and make up all kinds of crap.
You know,
like a large was doing that just to fuck
with me.
I know it.
And then you'd talk to them later.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty.
It's,
it's,
it's a curse and a gift that creativity,
you know,
how hard was it for you to get.
So Uber
a fear was a big motivator in that for
me,
you know,
losing my family was.
That was,
that was the thing that scared me so
much.
That was the bottom.
I hit that my family is going to go away
because of my behaviors that I brought
home from the road.
I got kicked out of the house by my
wife.
I was living on my own somewhere and I,
you know,
I did not want that and maybe as part of
my upbringing,
you know,
um,
my family Kinda desitin graded when I
was a kid,
you know,
father left my mother pass away,
I live with my brother and then Kinda
just all like the family,
you know,
where'd my stuff go,
where,
where it just kind of floated away and I
do not want that happening,
you know,
no matter what's going on,
we're going to talk this stuff out and
make it work,
you know,
and my wife's have the same,
uh,
same idea,
same thought that,
you know,
her,
her family,
she was the invisible kid too,
you know,
so we relate a lot.
So there's no way we're going to let you
know,
any argument,
get in the way or just,
you know,
we're survivors,
we're survivors and we're gonna.
We're gonna talk through it no matter
how much and you know,
she,
she did the right thing.
She kicked my ass,
right the hell out of the house,
you know,
and um,
that scared the shit out of me.
So.
And she said,
hey,
you're not just going to the therapist
now in nuts talking about this.
You got to go and sort this shit out.
So that's what I did.
So Rehab did Rehab really worked for me.
Helen,
Jeff,
to go for a while.
What worked for me was a
seven weeks someplace like basically
tearing you down to bones,
ripping your life apart.
Anything you thought about yourself or
what it was,
anything you thought you had,
your family,
your career,
your,
anything gone strip you down to just,
okay,
you're born.
Here's how you were when you were born.
You were okay,
you're a good,
good person.
Let's get back to that again.
And then they slowly rebuild you.
And then I went to a,
uh,
another they call them aftercare places.
I went there,
uh,
to a couple different ones and they fine
tune stuff and get integrated back into
life.
Because when you're in this cocoon and
your,
your frigging raw,
I mean,
I was raw meat when I came out.
And you can see it in that some kind of
monster movie.
I was pretty raw still.
I didn't know what I could or what I
should or shouldn't do,
you know.
Um,
so the,
the last place we went to was a place
that helps relationships,
so they got me and my wife together and
we'd see people separately and then come
together and talk about what we did and
communication frigging saved my life,
saved our family.
Um,
and working through that stuff.
So very grateful for my wife.
She's the one that didn't ask for this
shit.
She walked through fire with me and we
walked out together stronger,
way stronger than we ever would have
been before.
And you know,
my kids know my story,
my kids know my struggles and
they respect that.
They respect me and a different way.
I don't have to tell them what to do all
the time or just be like,
I'm this.
I can say sorry.
I can tell them,
hey,
here's what happened when I did that.
And you know,
I don't need to preach to them.
They got their own stuff,
but now they,
now they goof with me.
I ruined my trust with my family.
And now by some miracle they are goofing
with me.
It's like,
Dad,
shut up.
What do you get them like,
come on,
you know,
your overblowing this your way out of
dad,
you're taken up way too much space here.
Okay.
So they helped me and I realized that
there is help in a loving way.
How long have you been sober now?
15.
Fifteen years.
Did it start out when you,
when you first started doing it,
did it feel like as you broke through
and you,
you,
you know,
you went to therapy and you got out of
Rehab and you,
you're going through this whole thing.
Was there a,
like a shaky leg period where you're
like,
man,
do I know who I am anymore?
Oh,
absolutely.
That was,
it was.
That is the power of the mind and how,
you know,
here's how my life works.
And to actually just completely throw
that away and start over,
it's like,
well,
wait a minute,
who am I without this?
Um,
uh,
I can't talk to people.
I'm like,
I'm anxious,
I'm shy.
I'm all of the stuff that I thought
booze was helping me with or you know,
you know,
booze,
drugs,
women,
a shopping,
eating,
gambling,
you know,
there's so many things that can manifest
out there that it's,
it all goes back to one core thing.
It's like I don't,
I don't really know who I am.
So it took years and years and years to
figure out,
okay,
I like that.
That's part of me and this is part of
me.
The anger,
the,
you know,
the quirkiness,
the dark part of me,
all these little things that make me,
I got to hug him,
I to accept him,
you know,
and quit running from him and pretending
like I am some immovable object on
stage.
That's tough and you know,
nothing can do,
you know,
nothing going to hurt me.
But inside,
yeah,
it's kind of a cliche saying that,
you know,
the harder that external shield,
the softer the inside and the more
vulnerable and,
and balancing that,
you know,
almost like you're concentrating so much
on the outside that you ignore the
inside.
Totally.
And then forget what I really want.
And then you lose yourself in that
other,
that other person and yeah,
being in a band certainly accelerated
that,
you know,
there's,
there was drink and drug and all kinds
of stuff just thrown at you all the time
and it's starts off as a fun little
thing and then it turns into whiskey and
escape and then all of a sudden you
don't really,
you don't remember why you're out there
doing stuff.
I went on tour just so I could go to the
Strip club,
you know,
hey,
we're going to this place,
you know,
and over going to drink here.
And you know,
knew all that stuff.
But the actual playing onstage,
it kind of got forgotten about a little
bit,
you know,
it was.
We get caught up in the rockstar stuff
and there's a,
there's a song on this album,
moth into flame that directly talks
about the how fame can be this crazy
drug.
And it can completely take you over if
you let it,
you know,
you're searching for that thing that's
going to save you.
And it's,
it's you,
it's in your,
it's already there.
You just gotta you just gotTa find it
and accept it.